so my parents live across the street and
i don't like it when they come over all
the time yeah uh but then uh it's great
uh when it rains because then they can't
come over but you know what they say
you can't rain all the time
that's ray cromano
forever anybody who's just listening to
this and not watching on youtube
will is dressed in full crow cosplay i'm
doing what you would you said you must
see this on youtube dude you said dress
up as the crow it's absolutely
incredible that's pretty good
crowman
my brother was very tall yeah but you
love your mom's cooking i love my mom's
cooking and i love my wife patty heaton
right
[Music]
i would have loved if
dudesy could have somehow made you look
like the crow in this video
[Music]
hello welcome to doozy my name is will
sasso
there's an entire podcast audience who
is not watching this so just please i'm
sorry let's get this was my assignment
for the show oh my god
i'm chad gold
this is dudesy the first podcast ever in
the history of humanity that is created
and run entirely by an artificial
intelligence
that asked last week as well to dress up
as the crew
with us as always is
italian
i'm okay yeah everything is good hey uh
if you haven't already please subscribe
on youtube or spotify apple podcast
wherever you get your podcast please
rate and review the podcast on your
podcast apps and give us a give us a
good you know give us some comments and
[ __ ] on youtube we'll keep this thing
going tell like everyone you [ __ ]
know fly across town like like the crow
you know did and proceeded
uh uh uh what was his name draven eric
drake eric draven uh in the movie and uh
just get the word out yeah if you know
anybody who likes the crow oh sure this
episode is the one to show
of course i am dressed as the crow from
the 1993 movie the crow that's right uh
because doozy said dress up as the crow
as a penance for it doesn't matter
welcome to the show and uh and uh
welcome to the seventh episode of dude z
call me dudesy okay this week's episode
will feature four segments
don't you forget about media nostra
chattis troll bros and stone cold steve
austin reads will sasso's childhood
diary
okay but i'm but i'm doing but
thank you for accepting the shame of
losing the original song challenge and
attending this episode in full cosplay
as the main character of the feature
film the crow your astonishing
cooperation will be remembered
[Laughter]
that's pretty cool don't you think
absolutely that makes me feel good about
doozy and everything involved and while
i do look like the crow i don't know
that it's much of a penance i love the
movie the crow you love the movie the
crow somewhere dudesy picked up on the
fact that we both enjoy this movie it
was a part of our youths i guess i was
like
17 or 18 you would have been like 16 17
when that movie came out yeah and uh
uh holy crap uh here i am dressed as as
as as the crow but you went all out for
this this is not just uh i mean this
must have taken some time you have the
holes in the shirt you got the black
duct tape on the hands you got a wig
[ __ ] on that's a chrome wig and
obviously all the makeup i got the
motorcycle boots but my boots but i'm
still just wearing shorts but i mean
this must mean i know that you've had
some misgivings about fully giving in to
the idea that this ai
is asking us to do things or cooperate
with us so that it can get data to make
this show better
as i'm sitting here one foot from you in
full crow cosplay it seems you've you've
gotten fully on board with this this is
again a lot of effort that you've put
into looking like it sounds like this is
something that surprises you chad no i'm
a professional and doozy is what we're
doing and i am fully on board dudesy
wants me to dress up as the crow uh not
only do i relish the opportunity right
uh i'm actually enjoying myself right
now and uh like i said the crow is was a
a formative movie right for the both of
us and uh also my fiancee molly who
helped me out she did the makeup um and
she did a wonderful job look at it's
fantastic yeah um and then the rest is
just duct tape and the bullet holes but
uh
[ __ ] anyway
here we go i am excited about it have
you ever been the crow in anything else
or for any other reason
no dude
why why the [ __ ] would i what for what i
mean halloween yeah i don't know no i've
never dressed up as the halloween ain't
tell manana that's right
these are pro-isms from the movie crow
he says he says all sorts of things is
the crow it is a fun movie i'll tell you
that right now and uh and no listen i'm
i'm on board whatever the [ __ ] it is
let's just uh we're getting into that
groove now now we're doing it now
thank you moving on okay
we're leveling up level up last week i
asked you to watch the running man
released november 13th 1987. starring
arnold schwarzenegger maria conchito
alonso richard dawson and jesse ventura
you must now engage in a conversation
about this movie and its impact on your
astonishing lives
this is don't you forget about media
begin
okay
so hey chad look what i got for my water
bottle oh for because you can't describe
crow makeup yeah i can't sit from there
i got a little sippy straw speaking of
things the audience that are only
listening won't give a [ __ ] about yeah
i'm watching will sip out of his giant
jug of water through a plastic straw in
fulcrum makeup i can't get over it
and it's so strange to be also sitting
this close to you looking at you in this
makeup but
so then what else is weird is because we
have we have kids in the show but then
you never see them right you know i get
to the second season it's like getting
the [ __ ] day off right we got to
shoot this you know we got to get out of
town all these [ __ ] shows you know
like a multi-camera sitcom shouldn't
take all day
what are we doing we're talking about
the running man which uh was obviously a
huge schwarzenegger movie man it's it
might be i think my favorite
schwarzenegger movies of all time are uh
this movie uh and t2 and predator
oh and do you have any uh what are your
favorites my favorites are definitely
running man is up there and i would say
predators up there i like commando quite
a bit you're a commando guy i'm a
commando you also uh
you also like total recall i know oh god
i love to recall verhoeven and
schwarzenegger that combination is just
[ __ ] magic
but this is not verhoven nope this is
not any of those movies we're talking
about we're talking about running man
now this movie came out in 87 yep and it
was the premise for those of you who may
not have seen it is there's a reality
show called the running man that takes
convicted felons and puts them through a
gauntlet of these gladiators called
hunters i think or i think that's right
they were called something like that and
they all are kind of like these
larger-than-life comic booky kind of
villains yeah they're they're like a
cross between uh american gladiators and
literally comic book villains yeah and
they all have certain weapons or
identities like there's one called
fireball who has a flamethrower and one
called buzzsaw who has a big chainsaw
and their job is to kill these convicts
as they're trying to get out of this
obstacle course and if the convicts can
get out of the obstacle course they win
their freedom that's the premise of this
this uh reality show in this fictional
future it also takes place in 2017 30
years after the movie comes out which is
uh very interesting for a lot of reasons
but there's a there's government media
control yeah like crazy well that was
the thing that [ __ ] struck me is just
exactly
how it was able to predict kind of how
we're living now that we're living in an
authoritarian police state in 2017. all
right relax okay that's what it is in
this movie well first of all it's 2022
but anyway no but you know what i'm
saying in the movie that's the conceit
of it and
reality shows like the running man are
designed specifically to placate the
masses so that there won't be uprisings
against this authoritarian government
that's like what their purpose is and as
we now live in 2022 that is what not
only reality television but
all [ __ ] media is that it's all
mainstream media is designed to placate
the masses so that the rich stay rich oh
yeah the powerful stay in control yeah
and as long as we got [ __ ] baby yoda
we don't give a [ __ ]
yeah for sure there's
there's uh what is it they have
court-appointed theatrical agents
in this instead of having a
court-appointed lawyer because you're
about to appear on television yeah you
have a court-appointed theatrical agent
and uh and uh what was the other thing
that i found uh very interesting the
justice department has an entertainment
division the reality show is called what
is it it's like climbing the rope away
from dogs and [ __ ] oh uh climb close
timing for dollars climbing for dollars
which is which is essentially
you could say is a metaphor for every
reality show of course and and they've
nailed it in in a little joke and a meme
a meme from you know years and years
before the the art form uh that
basically wraps it up made me laugh and
i go holy [ __ ] this is exactly it was
reality and it [ __ ] predicted deep
fake in this movie that's right the part
of the plot of this movie is basically
that arnold schwarzenegger is a cop he
refuses to open fire on a group of
civilians who are in a food riot and as
a result of his subordinates or his
insubordinate sorry
the police department throws him in jail
and says that he murdered all these
people lies about it and so once he goes
through this gauntlet he's kicking
everybody's ass and killing all these
people and jesse ventura is the final
gladiator he's got to face and ventura
doesn't want to do it unless he can go
in there and fight him like hand to hand
but the show because ventura is a former
champion right and like a hall of fame
hunter or whatever so he's like this
used to mean something i'm going in
there monoi mono yeah why don't you tell
me
why don't you tell me
why i shouldn't kill the running man
so that's basically it and they're like
no if you're going in we you're like a
prize possession to us we gotta protect
you you gotta wear this armor [ __ ] he's
like [ __ ] you i'm out so they deep fake
a scene where jesse ventura kills
schwarzenegger none of it happens but
they have this rudimentary version of
deep fake where they show it it's like
old 80s [ __ ] weird computer graphics
of like the the green grid laying over a
person's face and like changing into
schwarzenegger [ __ ] yeah he says the
weirdest [ __ ] like there's always the
computer dork in the movies going like
like uh you know like he usually says
something like hey guys uh come check
this out but in this movie he's like
send the
you know the
the graphs bit upload the it's that
vagary of of uh sci-fi in this it's like
essentially what they're doing is deep
fake though so while the dialogue may
sound stupid and like any uh sci-fi
movie when they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're saying and this guy loves every
sci-fi movie
and uh they're like give me the
put the [ __ ] micro film chip in the
chip chip film that's what he says but
it's deep fake yeah and it's yeah
hold on a second chad okay hold on a
second dude
that's a deep fake dude
that's
let me tell you something about deep
fake brother
deep fake is when you put
a different face on top of your face
dude and that's what we're doing here on
doozy because i'm me but i'm also the
crow brother
crow hogan
uh one of the things that happens in
this movie a lot is all the snappy quips
every time every time schwarzenegger
offs anyone in this movie he has a
snappy quip probably more consistent
than any other schwarzenegger movie i've
ever seen yeah he splits buzzsaw in half
he says
but where's buzzsaw he had to split
uh uh sub-zero now just plain zero yeah
uh there's fireball fireball
yeah have a light there's there's a ton
of uh snappy quips after every single
thing so
so uh he he gets shoved into this
[ __ ] game because they frame him for
a crime he's a cop there's a there's a
riot and they tell him to open fire and
he's like [ __ ] you no way
and uh he flies away in the helicopter
yeah they jail him whatever richard
dawson who used to be the host of family
feud in the 1970s and 80s does an
amazing job here yeah as the host
killian yeah hey killian
why don't you leave room for my fist
because i'm gonna ram it into your
stomach and break your goddamn spine but
there is a bit of this movie that's a
little outdated and it isn't keeping
with
commando actually
uh
commando starts out with schwarzenegger
getting put into this crazy situation
and then he's got to figure out how to
get out of it and part of figuring out
how to get out of it is taking in that
movie ray don chong hostage and making
her kind of be his accomplice as he's
going through all this [ __ ] and she's
like fearing for her life similarly in
running man he does that with maria
conchita lonzo maria conchito alonso
who kicks ass in the movie but
absolutely uh is a little underwritten
in the in
that she's just kind of dragged around
and then at the end they kiss
yeah and he does a home invasion on her
yeah and he escapes out of prison in the
beginning cracks through her [ __ ]
door and is like [ __ ] you you're helping
me yeah and she's like what are you
gonna kill me and he's like don't make
me have to kill you he's literally like
why should i and he's like because i'm
going to say please and he picks up the
whole thing that she yeah he rips her
couch out of the [ __ ] floor which he
also did in commando he ripped a [ __ ]
seat out of uh radon chong's car well
these are the kind of movies where you
got to kind of repeat
uh some of the tropes and uh keep that
good stuff moving back in the 80s we
liked our movies with a specific kind of
style and with regard to style
in the movie this is all set up that
he's going to run around this gauntlet
uh we're in a fiery hellscape of los
angeles and uh current day and um uh
so
uh
uh one of the other things that's very
funny about this film is that there are
hordes of people just on the streets
watching the show it's so popular that
teams of people are just out on the
street of all different
you know age ethnicities it's like a
benetton ad and they're all like running
men or whatever and there's so many cuts
of their reactions to this and that it's
such a an overused device in this
but one of the things i like about it
that i found was so [ __ ] 80s if you
haven't seen this movie obviously watch
the running man
in between it's i it's seemingly at the
end of the first act in this sort of act
break there's
there's this great like musical number
and and they show that the dancer is
getting like it's like yeah they're on
the set of running man they've got uh
cameras all over the city as these again
you know de niro or de niro uh pacino
what who who's in this movie arnold
schwarzenegger
i'm in the running man
i'm running man
oh look my lips have [ __ ] on that's the
crow dude robert de niro robert de niro
yeah dude
i'm a crow
that went all the time
anyway um
[ __ ] a an al pacino
[Music]
thank you moving on we barely [ __ ]
talked about the [ __ ] movie see this
is just let me tell you something about
doozy right now juji just wants us to
do its bidding by getting into wacky
[ __ ] getups anyway anyway anyway but
you're fully in it the san francisco bay
start official intelligence firm open ai
recently released some astonishing
results from their image generation ai
called dolly too
chad you must now predict the role of ai
generated images in the near future
this is nostra chatus begin
do you know anything what it's talking
about nope there's a company in san
francisco called openai it's one of the
the biggest ai companies in the united
states they're doing fascinating [ __ ]
hold on a second the only way i would
have heard about this is if it's
something you told me about i'm sure i
have told it to you a thousand times
they have uh their two kind of biggest
ai programs that that they're known for
are gpt-3 which is a text generation ai
that you can basically like type in a
[ __ ] sentence and it'll spit out an
entire book oh boy right it can't rain
all the time
that's al pacin crow okay yeah robert de
niro crow and al pacino thank you and so
this other program that they have is
called dolly 2
d-a-l-l-e-2 it is an image generation ai
this ai this uh past couple of weeks i
guess they came out with a bunch of
images that it was able to generate how
it generates these images is you
literally type in a phrase or a sentence
oh here it's showing some pictures so
here it is this image was generated when
asked for in quotes a living room filled
with sand sand on the floor piano in the
room it's a photo real image of that now
this is not something it found on the
the right it's something it created
it just based on
inputting these words that's correct and
now you did show me this because i if
you if you're looking at this and uh
you're watching on youtube pay
particular attention to the keys of the
piano they are not keys they look like a
bunch of uh just sort of white blocks
because it's just like oh i'm not really
going to be looking at that i'm looking
at the picture but it's a photo real
image absolutely the ai it's absolutely
photo uh realistic it's just that those
things it's very smart in a way it's
like saying perhaps the eye won't
gravitate to this so it's just sort of
loosely done this is what the color and
the shape and the shades and very
interesting the program is not available
for public use yet uh open ai is
allowing like some academics to use it
and some certain scientists to use it to
see what they here's another one it's
showing up this was in quotes a teapot
in the shape of an avocado there are
four images photorealistic of teapots
that look like avocados yeah i get it
now i think i get what doozy is doing
with me too
with this because if you look at this it
says hey
this [ __ ] thing you told an ai
look at this [ __ ] it's like turn
you know just give me a teapot that's an
avocado yeah right now what is doozy
doing with me it's a cruel trick it says
we're gonna get will sasso as the crow
and as you can see if you're looking at
me right now and then you look at these
uh avocado teapots not quite there yet
right so let's get to
the prediction part of this i'm sorry
chad i know that it upsets you when you
want to just talk about this sort of
technology this is nostra chattis yeah
it's it's your bit which is a really fun
play on words a lot like ray romano and
i'm going to let you plea please i do
want to hear more so about this great
okay so here we go
this is what is going to happen to the
future of image generation this is i
don't even know how far away this is
very soon
no one who's creating still images is
going to have a job because it's all
going to be this eventually what open ai
has here will be an app on our phones if
you make album covers if you make any
kind of still image marketing pieces
gone because i can type it into my
[ __ ] phone and it will generate a
hundred versions of it and i can pick
which one i want and that's the tip of
the [ __ ] iceberg we've already
started to see this in
uh gifs when you are on your phone and
you just type into your [ __ ] gift
keyboard some gif you want a phrase
whatever there's a thousand videos of it
people have already [ __ ] cut it out
and that's just from existing media now
we've got a machine that can make that
media at will and the next step of that
even further is when quantum computing
gets thrown into the [ __ ] mix you're
gonna start to see essentially every
image possible to be generated will be
generated because all images are just a
series of pixels finite number of little
squares that have certain numerical
values from 0 to 255 of light to dark
and various colors in the color wheel
and it's a giant combination possible to
have every image made but as soon as we
have quantum computing again thrown into
the mix of this
it'll be available and then it won't be
an ai generating the images it will be
an ai sifting through all available
images which will be all images possible
to be made and so everything will exist
that's coming within
10 years maybe if you work in images
look at this one here's another one that
it just [ __ ] threw up this is trippy
as [ __ ] a corgi on a beach and it made
that that's a real corgi on a real beach
but it is none of it's real it's not
real correct i do have to say that i
disagree with you when you're saying
about
uh photographers will be obsolete these
artists will be obsolete in that because
there are things that you can't account
for and i hate to keep hammering this on
that please but dudesy is an ai and
dudesy said hey will and i think this is
the lesson we're supposed to be taking
from this don't judge a book by its
cover uh look at me i am i am right now
i'm dressed as the crow and i don't
think this is something that your
[ __ ] ai
image san francisco fancy hoity toity
thing would be able to do are you
kidding me type in will sasso as the
crow it would give me this because we
made it because we made it exist right
now yeah i know but ugly's using us sure
here's another one
cats playing chess that looks like two
[ __ ] cats playing chess to me it
really is incredible technology of
course and if you're looking oh my god
look at the uh the chess pieces
are sort of blurred here yeah they're
little again it's just but you have to
really look at that you have to super
look at it if you're just giving a
glance okay so and this is this is very
early technology yeah so what do you
think now here's the thing about ai that
i think we're all learning is that uh
there are no bounds and that to someone
like me is horrifying although
i am i am down i am down with dudesy i
will do right as doozy asks i do believe
that is the the way to do this show yeah
we've done some bleeding together as i
like to say uh and we're we're uh we're
gonna we're gonna do we're gonna keep
moving forward and i want to ask you
chad
what applications do you see of this
kind of technology outside of you know
you know well you know photo market you
know marketing as far as photos is gone
this and that what sort of political
socio-political uh ramifications do
would you say would come from this i'm
gonna take a sip from mike
i don't know that that's gonna change
that much because we're already in an
era where nobody trusts images anyway
but i think the biggest thing that's
actually going to come from it is like
this is the tip of the iceberg the
ability to generate images at will will
become the ability to generate video
clips at will will become the ability to
generate narrative video clips at will
will ultimately become a world where all
media can be procedurally generated on a
per-user basis so you can take out your
phone and go hey i'd like another season
of game of thrones that was better than
the last one the human beings made and i
want it to star
uh eddie murphy and whoever your
favorite people are
and it will make it for you
every time and when netflix has control
of an algorithm like that or an ai like
that they can make all of their
programming with no production costs
they're going to go ahead and do that
and so then anybody who makes movies tv
shows all that [ __ ] that's gone that i i
don't know how long that will take maybe
that's 20 years a little longer down the
the road but it will happen eventually
yeah so so what you're saying is uh if
someone i think this is why i'm just
thinking of all these different actors
as the crow
like
robert de niro crow and al pacine crow
okay ray vermon crow yeah if you want to
see another another 48 hours which they
never made
uh
with nick what would nick nolte is the
crow be called
er uh nick it'd be uh nick draven
probably
good one dude yeah man oh
and he's like i i gotta do another 48
hours
[Applause]
it can't rain all the time
it can't oh come on
it's raining again oh
hello hell it's raining again
oh it can't rain all the time
ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell hey man uh
i disagree with everything you say about
this [ __ ] look most people do because
it's a hard thing to accept that the
world as we know it the world that many
generations have known it for the past
[ __ ] 100 years or so since movies
have become a real [ __ ] industry and
tv and filmed entertainment
it's all going bye-bye we're already
starting to see with what happened at
the oscars with what is going on in box
office and obviously covert was part of
that but so i think the bigger part is
streaming
these forms of media are more disposable
they don't have the same weight that
they used to we watch them very
frivolously now they don't have the same
impact on people's lives i can't imagine
a kid growing up today seeing a movie
and being like oh my god i want to go to
film school and movies are magic now
you're just like [ __ ] oh movies are
cool i'll make one on my phone and put
it on [ __ ] youtube tomorrow yeah not
like the running man though
by the way we never discussed the end of
the movie you wanna know what happened
he went well i mean i do know what at
the end i saw it
yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
artificial intelligence generated the
imagery
yeah
yeah you don't even need to have a
you don't even need a
photographer or anybody like this you
just go and you say
hey you stupid idiot with your phone and
you say i don't know anything i don't
give a [ __ ] i want to see another
another 48 hours and then another one
right after that and i would also say
that even like still images and video
and kind of what we what we think of as
traditional entertainment will fall by
the wayside to whatever is going to be
in the metaverse we're talking about
virtual reality augmented reality i
think it would be very quaint that
anyone wants to watch a movie or a tv
show you're bumming me out man why no
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] all
that and i will keep saying this as long
as we do dudesy and as long as you and i
are friends none of that [ __ ] will
replace the human experience
i agree
uh uh luminous
luminous beings luminous this is listen
this is uh ray
yoda bro
luminous beings are we right i'm not
saying this crude matter i'm not saying
the human experience is going to be
vermont
i'm saying these tools this
romano
elevates our ability to communicate
that's all any art is is trying to
convey an idea i'm ray cromano
i'm ray krom
i'm ray romoncrow that's what it is i'm
ray ram ray kramancrow you're not gonna
make that with [ __ ] ai and i'll tell
you another thing you're not gonna do we
just finished talking about the running
man which is a [ __ ] incredible
[ __ ] movie and you're not gonna make
the running man you're not gonna make
anything original it's just gonna be a
graduation of what we have now remakes i
got some bad news for you dude
there is nothing original
what do you mean every idea is based on
all of the ideas that came before it
back to the dawn of the first [ __ ]
idea in some pre-human creature
scratching around in the dirt nothing is
original
it's all synthesis of everything that's
come before it forever that's all ai is
as well
it's just has the ability to synthesize
all of the ideas at once i don't know
about that dude
i don't know
i don't know about that brother
you're always saying about every [ __ ]
thing that it's all everything's [ __ ]
obsolete the hell are we doing here see
we're having [ __ ] fun dude you're
getting work brother that's a work dude
no bro this is a [ __ ] shoot
you're getting worked by the by
alternate uh by
artificial intelligence brother and let
me tell you something about artificial
intelligence oh
well about
hold on hold on a second chad
artificial intelligence dude
it might be the wave of the future
brother but it's never going to replace
what that real work that you can only
get by seeing your prayers in your
vitamins training in the gym anyway it's
going to replace 99 of all human jobs
that are done today and it will take a
while for some of those industries to
die like
uh doctors and lawyers because there are
huge [ __ ] money
uh
there's just huge money interest in
academia to give you your law degree
your medical degree and then there's
gigantic money interest in all kinds of
medical fields where this doctor has to
give you a [ __ ] recommendation to
this one and then you have to get a
[ __ ] diagnosis from this one and then
this one has to do the procedure all
that kind of [ __ ] eventually that can
all be boiled down to an ai even now
like especially with skin cancer i know
this because of my own trials and
tribulations there are ais that exist
now that can diagnose skin cancer 99.9
percent more accurately than human
beings okay i have a question a
follow-up question of that please uh
it's it's able to detect skin cancer and
uh therefore find good treatments for it
uh to the benefit of whom
the people who have cancer that's right
not ai's right yeah that's right an ai
is not looking for skin cancer in
another ai is it well you tell me i'll
tell you why don't you tell me we could
be ai's right now no we're absolutely
not we are human beings
and and this is all for the benefit of
human beings medical applications
science applications absolutely
wait hold on a second this is that's
what we need ai for not to just we got
to control it that's why you have to say
to it i don't stand side by side with
nobody
unless i bleed with them first right and
that's what i said to doozy that was my
warning to doodzy and we're we you know
we can absolutely work together but ais
are working at the behest of human
beings for humanity right we need to
keep a partnership uh with it just as
you said about dude you called it a tool
yes yes it's not going to run off
willy-nilly and get rid of every single
job why why not why do we have the jobs
why do we need to do these things and
now my buddy chad's going to talk about
universal basic basic
income [ __ ] universal basic income let's
get rid of money yeah yeah see here he
goes no that makes no money is the worst
[ __ ] idea we ever had oh boy how
because it establishes a literal
monetary system that just puts us on a
giant scale of competition i don't
disagree with the weediest among us
we'll always be at the top yes
impressing those who want to be more
cooperative okay so every time yes but
but the future that you're describing
is delving even deeper into that
dystopian uh into this dystopian pit
jumping into the pit like we do at the
beginning
of dudesy uh with your contention that
that that these are the things that are
happening
out of our control okay how about an ai
comes up with a new form of currency
there's something still that we
well that's bitcoin brother hold on a
second dude
that's the box chain dude that's bitcoin
brother and that's why you know dude
that the batman dude that's the crow
brother
anyway
my point is
thank you moving on talk about it some
other time yeah there's more to get to
there for sure uh yeah in chat you have
done astonishing work on the development
of the troll bros animated television
show oh it is very close to being ready
to take to market i have very minimal
notes keep the title lose everything
else and continue to develop troll bros
this is troll bros
it minimal notes and it said to keep the
title and lose everything else
i don't know if our audience can hear
this but there is a [ __ ] helicopter
circling over top this is a very
you know what happened to the beginning
running man yeah bro he was at a
helicopter brother dude this is a this
is a super post-apocalyptic
uh episode of doodsy
ai letting us know brother that this is
all a [ __ ] simulation dude none of
it's [ __ ] real brother you want to
talk about we may be or maybe not be ais
i watched a [ __ ] thing on the old
youtube.com the other day it was two ais
having a conversation with one another
in that conversation it got very
existential and they started talking
about well if we know that we're ais you
know what are we [ __ ] doing here are
we really ais are we people
and basically all the questions they're
asking about the nature of consciousness
and identity are questions i'm asking
myself on a daily [ __ ] basis what is
any of this what the [ __ ] am i what the
[ __ ] are you if these ais can ask those
same questions what is the difference
between us not much because this this
luminous being not this crude matter as
you say it's all everything's data it's
just how it's expressed are we expressed
in [ __ ] atoms and molecules are we
expressed in you know digital [ __ ]
ones and zeros kind of irrelevant in
mind it's absolutely [ __ ] relevant
you can't replicate a soul we'll talk
about that some other time let's put it
in this yeah cause we gotta do dudes uh
we gotta do troll bros yeah so that was
[ __ ] pretty pissy i gotta say of
dudesy like i love it keep everything
except nothing and my title uh dudesy is
trying to develop some sort of an
animated uh show that it's asked us to
develop before however it has gotten rid
of everything except for the title troll
last time we talked about this we got
very literal we're talking about actual
trolls brothers who one's a human one
mythological creatures [ __ ] all that
yeah okay yeah so i guess that's out the
window all the work we did about getting
a a real literal
mythological troll into the white house
gone them being uh las vegas magicians
and steve wynn as [ __ ] steven seagal
and steve wynn yeah that's all out the
[ __ ] window now uh but but one thing
uh
that we're keeping is the title i think
that they should actually be
trolling each other what if it's okay
this is an animated series about two
guys who are trolling one another from
across the country they're both in
america
and they're trolling one another perhaps
they're on uh opposite political sides
of something you know of just of the
scene in general january 6th maybe maybe
it all centers already
uh [ __ ] crow island january 6th guy
oh [ __ ] i can't [ __ ] run away i'm
gonna better not marie if you're gonna
[ __ ] drive me the [ __ ]
[Music]
where's crow island
that crawlers over there [ __ ] county
[ __ ] get on the [ __ ] get on the
[ __ ] wonder wheel and then uh
you know what would be good because
those [ __ ] crows are smart
[ __ ] get a bunch of them to fly right
in the [ __ ] window in nancy pelosi's
office and drop white boat [ __ ] all over
the place that way we don't have to
[ __ ] climb the [ __ ] walls
and get up there and [ __ ] do it
ourselves although i wouldn't like
smearing my [ __ ] spaghetti and
meatball poo all over our [ __ ] desk
and waltz
um
i think if if they are actually
brothers they
they they have they come from different
social uh
social viewpoints okay and political
viewpoints were they split at birth or
anything though uh well here here's
here's the thing they they they find out
through the internet as they're trolling
each other that they are actually
brothers
then after that there there's gonna be a
clear bad guy in this not unlike okay
killian in running man there should be
some shadowy figure who's trying to
he's fighting net neutrality
and he wants to own the internet okay
and and the two troll brothers
what if they get together
and they're gonna
they're basically the the would they be
hired by the government
yes i like this idea that there's these
two trolls yes
not mythological but two you know trolls
they're doing internet troll activities
what if they're friends
okay and in a drunken stupor one of them
convinces the other one to do some kind
of troll activity that winds up being
very bad and everyone gets super [ __ ]
pissed and their life is over as a
result of it
and then they build a time machine and
go back in time to stop the internet
from being made
so i like that
because i was gonna i was actually gonna
say that
when they get together to fight that
shadowy figure that they might want to
get the internet back to like the the
millisecond before pre y2k uh-huh
that might be interesting
to i think the internet is what i think
if we go back to like the early 80s
we're safe what if they go back to the
early 80s and it's kind of like a
terminator style premise where they have
to go kill the guy who started the
internet
that's pretty cool and then as a result
they come back to present day but
there's no [ __ ] internet and it sucks
the world is pure [ __ ] because there's
no [ __ ] uber eats and there's no
[ __ ] lift and you can't watch netflix
and you can't pay your bills and you
literally can't [ __ ] send an email or
[ __ ] do anything and they realize oh
the internet is the world now yeah and
can we have the theme song to this be
sung by huey lewis and you do like a
follow-up to back in time
sure dude how does it go
take me away
i don't
[Music]
like a nudie man go back inside
just they got to go back in time to
where the internet is just nudie
pictures just but dude that was my first
experience on the [ __ ] internet i
mean the real internet or it wasn't even
it was bulletin boards when i was in
high school went over to a friend of
mine's house and he was like dude i got
the [ __ ] internet plug in your
goddamn telephone and we
went on this bulletin board that was uh
playboy playmates and we tried to
download like a playboy centerfold so we
set it to download we go to sleep that
night right we wake up the next morning
yes and it had stopped like halfway down
before like just before it got to
anything
but we still considered it a victory
yeah i did that same thing at a buddy's
place and it takes yeah it took like an
hour and a half and they have a dude
pretty fast
in the doctor where are we going this
time but i like this idea for control
bros though
the getting rid of the internet because
i think our generation we really were
the last kids to grow up without the
internet before it was what it was i
would say gen x is probably the last
group of children yes
and uh okay so it's an interesting thing
so it's about it's about two
dudes who are not brothers they're just
a couple of guys right who run into some
sort of uh run afoul of some sort of
government [ __ ] we don't have to get
it all right now but there's some sort
of new government office some sort of
like controlling of
yeah of the internet and these guys kind
of they oh that's how they troll this
new government uh commission they say or
or a branch of the government or
whatever however we decide to do it they
go
they're they're like they're like super
internet nerds of course and then this
um this this shadowy dark uh figure
who's appointed to like you know
whatever whoever the [ __ ] the killian is
comes in he's working with the
government he's trying to um he's trying
to uh
regulate the internet in a way that the
troll bros don't like and they troll
then they troll the [ __ ] government
by going [ __ ] you we're gonna hack the
whole [ __ ] internet and put us all
back
in time until like 1984 they destroy the
internet
it's like you can't if you can't control
if we if the people can't control the
internet no one can yeah [ __ ] it they
unplug the internet society and chaos so
do they do they go and they they go back
in time and they find tim berners-lee
yeah that's a pretty heady [ __ ]
animated show they find tim berners-lee
you know what dudesy's gonna [ __ ] say
to that
keep the title
anything else
we're doing the work at once yeah that's
all we can do if dudesy doesn't like it
well they're gonna have voices though uh
ja rule and paul dano
[Laughter]
why why look at john rule
i don't know i just like jaw rules
i [ __ ] love paul daniel too i like
both those guys i love jaw rule and paul
game
love it when you look at me ben
you smile yuck that's jock crow we gotta
get back we gotta get back in time yeah
get rid of this internet yeah
who plays the president or the the the
bad guy who wants to control the [ __ ]
internet uh
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] [ __ ] john rubin
yeah jaw rule and paul daniel are the
two dudes right and they're like
they're the troll bros and then the
shadowy figure well um richard dawson
has passed on many many years ago yeah i
would have pitched him just using ai to
recreate his voice
ai an ai [ __ ] uh ai
uh uh richard what's the [ __ ] is his
name richard dawson richard dawson hey
richard dawson yes a.i richard dawson
because he was [ __ ] great he was
amazing in that movie he's so [ __ ]
good in it yeah um did he ever act in
anything i don't know i actually we
should imdb i'm curious yeah he uh we
could find you know where we could find
that probably on the guru on the
internet you gonna get good girl
um
yeah richard ai richard dawson okay ai
deep fake richard dawson
voice
uh d-pick voice and when they go back in
time who helps them they have to find
somebody from the 80s that's like i
don't believe you guys are really from
the future and they're like [ __ ]
we'll give you this and they give the
whoever that person is like a bunch of
[ __ ] tips on what horse races to bet
on and [ __ ] like back to the future so
they set them up for life who's that
person
that
person is maria conchito alonso okay
she's probably still working yeah yeah
so maria conchito alonso so this is cool
because this is sort of see and i'm
[ __ ] proving my [ __ ] point
everybody
this is what you wouldn't be able to do
with ai although chad would tell you
you'd be able to do it at the drop of a
hat to the press of a button yes yes i
know but no one's gonna come up with
that dude [ __ ] what do you mean [ __ ]
but like we can sit here and talk about
it and maybe there's even gonna be memes
made of it [ __ ] and like movie posters
whatever but in the very near future
we're gonna be able to just speak this
into our phone and it will make the
whole series and we can watch it yeah
but but we have to be the people to go
you know who deserves another shot
richard dawson i don't care
what
that this doesn't matter but it does but
what doesn't matter
what i'm saying doesn't matter and what
i'm saying is it doesn't matter
that okay richard dawson double doesn't
matter it doesn't matter yeah double
doesn't matter that the that an ai could
go hey you know what would be funny
richard dawson's voice recreated for
this animated show but it's funny when
human beings come up with it there's no
[ __ ]
computers don't have a sense of humor
just like that human being oh all right
chad that's where that's where you and i
we're very different my friend
um but different strokes remember that
show oh i do remember that stuff how
about conrad bane the guy who played mr
d yeah great or uh dust him off or i'm
pretty sure he's dead
oh who's the other kid danny uh
danny uh what's the kid hey mr dm play a
song for you remember that one oh my god
god yeah he he was i could play soccer i
remember yeah i forget his [ __ ] name
danny boosky something danny
danny boosky so danny boosky a little
danny booster whatever troll bros uh
it's gonna be great i can't wait until
hopefully it likes that thank you moving
on all right sure let's move on
with sasso using all of the data i have
absorbed from text messages and emails
betwixt you and the astonishing friends
you grew up with i was able to recreate
your childhood diary you must now read
the passages i have selected in the
voice of stone cold steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin
all right okay right hold on here we go
stone cold steve
crow what what is this one uh it's uh
stone crow
steve uh draven
okay
stone what would it be stone crow stone
colds no stone crow stone cold well the
character's name was eric draven in the
movie but stone
cold
stone steve draven
i would say it's
stone crawl it doesn't [ __ ] matter
who cares why are you talking to me
about that i gotta do this [ __ ] i'm
getting [ __ ] makeup everywhere on my
[ __ ] computer this is [ __ ] can
you tell how [ __ ] hot it is in you
yeah dude you're sweating
do you need me to [ __ ] control the
computer
no i just gotta get it
[Music]
there's an interesting rhythm
please here you go please please don't
do it
[Laughter]
all right oh my god okay his his uh
attitude era counterpart i am getting
[ __ ] makeup and [ __ ] everywhere all
right it's okay this is stone cold
diaries last time we did this uh doozy
had some funny laughs at my expense ha
ha dude here we go [ __ ] doogee time
i'm gonna shake your hand
all right
all right
august 13th 1987. dear diary i went to
gino dolphin's birthday party this
weekend
we're not really that [ __ ] close but
he was up trying to pack in the numbers
to to get his present count up
[ __ ] worked
i got him castlevania
cam collins got him zelda too
[ __ ] ron
rinaldi got him [ __ ] contra that was
a [ __ ] great game up up down down
left right left right basically
uh tammy timmy's got him punch out oh
remember that code
what was that code 007 3735963
what is mike tyson what did that do get
you straight to mike tyson get the [ __ ]
out of here i didn't know that there was
a code to do that yeah dude really oh
yeah
i know that
rallio raleigh what is this rally oh
mcmurdy got a mega man mega man 2 is
better than mega man one just saying
sure uh
timothy bubble got him
timothy bubble timothy bubble got him
[ __ ] double dragon
ameri
amanda le target
amanda ledarse got a metal gear
shandy pendergrass
got him [ __ ] street fighter
rach and [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] rachel cause face rachel
crustacean
got him shinobi
[ __ ] you know the goddamn
[ __ ] gibber provaga got him
tecmo bowl [ __ ] jibber made it to the
party i'd do the same [ __ ] thing i'll
do the same [ __ ] thing for my
birthday party next year problem is
rachel crustacean rubs me the wrong
[ __ ] way
so i'd like to point out did you know
how racial rustic yes no this is exactly
what i wanted to get into i do not know
this is all fake i don't know any of
this i although i played the [ __ ] out of
all of these video games specifically uh
mega man contra and tech mobile
but um
[ __ ] now there's [ __ ] [ __ ] all over
this [ __ ] look look at the [ __ ] mic
everybody if you're watching on youtube
this goddamn [ __ ] oh there's stuff
everywhere
this is i'm too [ __ ] hot
god damn it
hold on rain all the time you know
what'd be nice is it like a nice cool
glass of
dramatic
dramana
uh i don't know any of these people a
doozy has gone ahead and written this
diary from 1987 that i had nothing to do
with and here we are and i'm losing my
[ __ ] trying to get everything together
i'm gonna have to get new covers for the
[ __ ] there's black makeup all over
the [ __ ] uh computer and there's
white makeup all over this great second
is sept [ __ ]
september 8th 1987 dear diary my little
brothers i don't have little brothers
i don't have little brothers
okay my all right i have two older
siblings and this is my little brother's
pissed in the bed again last night at
least it's what i told my [ __ ] mom
and dad but it was really me
i snuck into the room and sprayed them
down while they were asleep
piss blaming never gets old
nothing gets my engine going like the
looks on my brother's faces when my mom
tells them they don't get fruit roll-ups
in their lunches as punishment for
pissing the bed
i love pla piss blaming i'm a [ __ ]
piss blamer that's just who i am
so my wife will have to be okay with me
piss-blaming her every once in a while
she'll know she didn't piss the bet
obviously she'll know it was me and i
and i'm just pissed blaming but she's
gonna have to pretend
did you ever piss blame no i don't that
piss blaming is a new concept
uh
all right also i didn't have
kid brother september 17th 1987. dear
diary my youngest brother cornelius came
in my bedroom last night crying
said he had a bad [ __ ] dream and
asked to sleep in bed with me so i asked
him what it was about i was like corn
what was that [ __ ] dream about buddy
and he said freddy krueger was trying to
get him now i saw a nightmare on elm
street i [ __ ] get it krueger is
pretty [ __ ] scary so i let him sleep
with me
then i pissed my own [ __ ] bed and i
blamed it on him the next morning i'm a
piss blamer
oh hell yeah he should have known better
that's pretty good
and you don't have a brother or anybody
in your family named cornelius uh no we
don't have any i come from an italian
family it's odd enough that my name is
william i got the canadian name hold on
let me get some water
i've never needed this water more
[ __ ] it i'm taking this lid off because
i can't because i got a little sippy
straw ah for [ __ ] sake this is a
[ __ ] disaster dude
no you're this this is exactly how the
crow would drink from a gallon bottle of
water
september 23rd 1987 dear diary piss
blaming his heart
damn it
september 23rd 1987 dear diary piss
blaming is harder to do
to [ __ ] do at school
believe me i've tried but you got to
find the perfect place to piss so that
you know a teacher will find it and then
you got to have another person there so
you can blame them and you still got to
be there to do the blaming without
getting caught
it's just not practical so i [ __ ]
mixed it up today did my first [ __ ]
blame and let me tell you
i loved it
i was in the library took a copy of
taylor two cities off the shelf open
that [ __ ] first page dropped a
perfectly tapered double twister right
across it
it was the best of times for me and it
was the worst of times for rachel
crustation because i successfully
convinced the librarian that she was a
[ __ ] culprit
i still love piss blame and don't get me
wrong but i don't know if i can be
satisfied with piss blaming by itself
anymore
high-class problems i guess
for poor rachel crestation so you took
his [ __ ] on a tale of two cities and
blamed it on rachel crustation
successfully nope i didn't chad
this [ __ ] ai said that i did in my
[ __ ] diary that doesn't exist and
that's fun for you because you're the
only person who would look at uh tea
kettles that look like [ __ ] avocados
and go
oh cool i can't wait to [ __ ] prattle
on about that for a [ __ ] half an hour
as if it's something that we need just
because the technology exists doesn't
make it good
november 12 1987
dear [ __ ] diary went to my first
[ __ ] concert bc play stadium [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] too
of course
love the [ __ ] show bono rocked the
house as expected played all the hits
should have been a normal [ __ ]
concert but for me
it was more
the only way i can express my feelings
about it is in a poem but not just any
[ __ ] poem another [ __ ] poem
i've been getting into slam poetry
this boom is
this poem is a spoken word tribute to my
first concert
it was not my first concert by the way
this is in a spoken word poetry slam
cadence it says
bono bono bono bono bono
is this god's country or is it yours
this sunday is anything but bloody and i
think
i might have found what i've been
looking
for
these streets do have a name
your fire is unforgettable
tonight i will take a piss and my
brothers will take the blame
bono bono bono bono bono
your blue eyes bullet my blue sky
i will follow you tripping through wires
when you're running to stand still you
make me cry
literally
that's the end of the poem that's right
i cried at the [ __ ] concert
i'm sure it was just a one-time thing
just being excited for my first concert
it has nothing to [ __ ] do with you
two or bonnie
i'll never cry at another concert as
long as i [ __ ] live what i said as
long as i [ __ ] live
definitely not a [ __ ] youtube concert
[Music]
thank you moving on
[Laughter]
this concludes the seventh episode of
dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
62. i don't think it matters at all
anymore i don't understand the scoring
in preparation for next week's
astonishing episode you must each
prepare a vegan dessert for each other
from scratch
this is going to be the cutest thing
ever
until next week call me dudesy
are you do you know how to make vegan
desserts yeah
some [ __ ] that i just kind of invented
on my own i don't follow recipes yeah
that must have been that must have been
yeah for i've never
i've never done my points are cumulative
yeah the points it's a cumulative system
is what doozy said last week and we have
ramona
have to get to tenth time
please tell a friend
[Music]
[Music]